[Music]
hi my name is Kate some ways I come from
Birmingham in England but I study in
Cardiff in Wales through the Erasmus
program I was able to spend some time
both in France and Italy as I study
French and Italian whilst in France I
worked at Disney Ursa which is Institute
and for my cheeks at avi Hall and there
I worked with disabled adults teaching
English for the second half of my year I
was in Venice Italy and there I studied
at the University named careful scurry
moving to France was a massive change
for me as it meant moving from the
capital city Cardiff to a small town it
was completely different for me to be
taught totally in one language I found
that even though I was learning facts in
that language I was also thinking about
the way they were being presented when I
was studying Italian in Cardiff I
remember thinking to myself this is
great but how could I really really
learn this language the best way to do
it is obviously go to the country then
you're speaking everyday and you're
picking up words without even knowing it
you're out for dinner with a friend and
you order a pizza and realize you just
learnt the word for mushroom or
something it's some very enriching
experience so do you think you would
ever go back definitely
I say when you get back it is quite
tough you get this kind of like Erasmus
blues because you just want to go back
again I would like to say thank you for
the opportunity to do Erasmus because it
means I've grown into a full rounded
individual and I know that when I
finished my studies I will maybe just
get that bit higher mark from doing
Erasmus and that will really help me out
in the job market in the future to
anyone who's thinking of doing a Rasmus
please just go and do it it's such a
great opportunity to go abroad meet
people improve your language learning
skills you'll be able to do everything
there so please just give it a go my
name is Marcela sublimino I live in shop
Anja Arden it's a beautiful region as
you can see 23 years old and then right
now standing in front of my school where
I run the industry of production and
management during this era CMAs program
in Romania I
in the company called hotel where I had
to accomplish a management project did
you improve your level in English yeah
because I had to speak English about
four three a month non-stop I had been
told before I go to Romania that it was
a very cold country I also had to to
find my technical words had been told
also that the people wasn't as friendly
as as they are actually and I noticed
that it was wrong it's not very easy to
speak English every day and to get used
to explain something you're feeling what
I learned in the company is that
whatever happens I have to keep on
trying and not to give up until
something is done it's a way to prove
your independence to prove that you can
make things by your own to prove that
you that you can be a self-made man
my name is Petra novikova I'm 22 and I
study media and history in Masaryk
University in Brno Czech Republic right
now I'm just finishing my internship
here at NATO headquarters in Brussels
with the Erasmus programme right now we
are in a meeting room number one
where normally the North Atlantic
Council takes place which is the highest
authority of the whole NATO it's a world
world itself I would say this whole
organization when you speak the
international English but you can meet
people from all around the world and you
can see the cultural differences you can
see people coming in in different
uniforms so what was the best during my
Erasmus day it's the culture you have in
here you're you flatmates your new
friends you make in here they let me do
things you know it was faster it's not
just that you do part of a work and you
don't really see the result but I was
lucky that during my stay in here there
was a six
years of NATO big celebration and
Strasbourg and Kel and I was part of the
team who organized a big conference for
students more than 300 and Strasbourg
you know discussing NATO's future so
that's something like really you know a
result you can see on the spot actually
I just got a job here in Brussels and
I'm considering to stay because I
already have my new friends and my new
life in here although I'm still working
on a bachelor thesis for my university
there was Moses actually the thing which
inspired me my name is Peter Murphy on
22 years old and I study industrial
design at the National College of Art
Design in Dublin Ireland
and thanks to my Erasmus stay in Finland
for five months not only did I study
industrial design but I partook in a lot
of other modules also including
architecture Finnish cuisine learning
the Finnish language furniture design
product design and life drawing when I
was there I loved it it was fantastic we
had an introduction week into our
college they had a lot of events planned
for us which was brilliant we went snow
hiking we went snow skiing
the Erasmus luck for me is somewhat up
by saying it's an adventure
it's about leaving everything you're
comfortable with and dropping yourself
into a different environment making new
friends learning new language living on
your own for the first time the host
institution that I stayed in Lahti it
was impeccable really really good
college very well funded by the
government which was nice to see they
had a lot of materials and other
workshops on offer I like I learned a
lot of new trades the tutors of my host
institution had a real hands-on approach
to design there was a great emphasis on
the final product for example I was
doing a product on designing chairs and
in Dublin we might have maybe a 3d
picture of the chair or very renard
sketches but in Finland I was actually
made to make the chair out of wood so
there was a whole learning process not
only was i sketching I was making the
piece out of wood and at the end of the
day I had a quite fantastic looking
finished product when I came back to
Dublin I was faced with normal life
again I had parents to deal with
I had a loan to pay off
job so it was sort of like the Erasmus
blues
[Music]